the executive the legislature the
Judiciary foreign policy government
policy civil rights even battles of
religion we're winning on every single
front this has been a bat banner week
and we have been winning on everything
we will analyze why and how then the
mailbag a lot to get to I'm Michael
Knowles and this is the Michael Knowles
show
[Music]
it's time to join the conversation again
did you know that the Supreme Lord of
the multiverse is up on Tuesday July
17th 5:30 Eastern 2:30 Pacific Andrew
Klavan answers your questions moderated
by whom by the beautiful and dauntless
Alicia Krause the Q&A will stream live
on YouTube and Facebook for everyone to
watch only subscribers can ask through
questions over at daily wire.com check
out the pinned comments on this video
for more information we're making it
easy serving it up to you on a silver
platter look at those pinned comments
once again subscribe to get your
questions answered by Andrew Klavan
Supreme Lord of the multiverse on
Tuesday July 17th that's 5:30 Eastern
2:30 Pacific and join the conversation
banner week folks we are bathing in
leftist tears all week on every single
front we'll explain why before we get to
that let me make a little money honey
let me keep the lights on in here you
know Ben has been chomping at the bit to
fire me since the day I met him I didn't
even work here before he wanted to start
firing me please go and check out
software advice software advice is a
really great solution if you have a
small business especially when you're
dealing with a real head-scratcher
having your go to person on call that's
a no-brainer that's why you've got to
find out about software advice you might
know this if you're a small business
owner if you've ever worked in a small
business or a you know startup
developing business there are a lot of
problems that you need to solve right
away and you need to have software
solutions for them now there are a lot
of clients and software's that you can
use and when you you've kind of look at
the reviews you say oh I don't know
should I pay because a lot of times
they're pretty expensive you know should
we pay this much for this per month
what's really the best tailor to my
business forget about all that you now
have someone in your corner can give you
all of the research that they've done
their team of advisers that software
advice can point you in the right
direction you can start working more
effectively right away how much does it
cost Michael how much do I have to pay
for all this incredible advice I knew
you'd ask that it's free people tell you
that nothing in this life is free will
software advice is and it's really
helpful it will save you a ton of money
and maybe more importantly a ton of time
when you're getting a business started
you just need some expertise right away
you'll otherwise you'll be spinning your
wheels go to software advice.com slash
oles Kano wles just like Beyonce answer
a few short questions about your
business you'll be connected to an
advisor to discuss the best software
options for your needs talking to an
advisor takes just 10 minutes or less
I'm a millennial I don't do anything
that takes more than 10 minutes it's
really good whether your medical
professional construction manager or HR
pro you name it so if we're advice we'll
save you time and help you make a more
informed decision and the software
struggle today I have done this in my
own business experience and it's cost a
lot of money in time go to software
advice.com slash Nolt SCANA wles to get
started I wish I had known about
software advice a few years ago it would
have saved me a lot of time and money
that is software advice com / Knolls
connect with an advisor for free
software advice calm / what / Knowles
what a week what a banner week for
winning on every single front and you've
got a balance at all I know some
cultural conservatives were worried
there's still a little bit worried about
judge Cavanaugh is judge Cavanaugh
sufficiently originalist sufficiently
pro-life meaning that he'll interpret
the Constitution as it actually is
written which does not have a right to
abortion is he sufficiently rock-ribbed
I don't you know that these are some
worries I will
I think lay out the case that on every
single front this week we are winning
even on judge Cavanaugh to begin the the
greatest video the greatest moment in
this presidency all week I know there
every week there seems to be a new one
but this is so beautiful Donald Trump
talking to a bunch of freeloading
Europeans as well as the German nation
the worst nation in the history of the
world which is destroyed civilization on
multiple occasions here is Donald Trump
talking to our NATO or freeloading NATO
allies but Germany is totally controlled
by Russia because they were getting from
60 to 70 percent of their energy from
Russia and a new pipeline and you tell
me if that's appropriate because
I think it's not and I think it's a very
bad thing for NATO and I don't think it
should have happened and I think we have
to talk to Germany better the top of
that Germany is just paying a little bit
over 1% whereas the United States in
actual numbers has paid 4.2 percent of a
much larger GDP so I think that's
inappropriate also you know we're
protecting Germany were protecting
France were protecting everybody and yet
we're paying a lot of money to protect
now this has been going on for decades
this has been brought up by other
presidents but other presidents never
did anything about it because I don't
think they understood it or they just
didn't want to get involved but I have
to bring it up because I think it's very
unfair to our country it's very unfair
to our taxpayer and I think that these
countries have to step it up not over a
10-year period have to step it up
immediately Germany is a rich country
they talk about thinking hey Greece it
is tiny bit by 2030 well they could
increase it immediately tomorrow and
have no problem I don't think it's fair
to the United States so we're gonna have
to do something because we're not gonna
put up with it we can't put up with it
and it's inappropriate oh we got to get
another batch just for those like
Bavarian tears or those Prussian cheer
tears rizona hmm very good only Donald
Trump could do this only president Trump
could do this and you know I'm a little
harsh on Germany I'm probably a you know
one and a half percent kidding I'm
ninety eight and a half percent serious
but you know a little bit
tongue-in-cheek but he's so right on
this point only president Trump could do
this every other president goes up he
say you know NATO's they're supposed to
be paying more just 2% of GDP there's
they're not even doing that though we're
paying 4% of GDP you know maybe maybe
they should could because we're
protecting them and they're undercutting
us at every turn and and then also
they're importing oil from Russia so
they're buying oil from Russia we are
paying to protect Europe from Russia
Russia Europe is using all of that money
to pay Russia this doesn't seem to make
a whole lot of sense for past presidents
can't do that because they don't want to
rock the boat this is an emperor has no
clothes a situation this is a situation
where all of the presidents come in and
they say well this is NATO NATO
been around for decades and decades and
decades and you know that's just the way
it works and they don't pay they're not
fulfilling their commitments but you
know well we should pay it this is how
it's always been
oh they're giving out money to rush it
well you know that's not good but that's
how it's always we can't change can't
touch NATO weaken NATO's been by the way
the Cold War has been over for what
thirty years now but oh no we can't
touch NATO this relic of the Cold War no
no no we can't do that and President
Trump comes in he looks at it he says
hold on I'm sorry maybe I'm maybe I'm a
little thick maybe I'm a little stupid
because I haven't been in Washington for
my entire life but the way it looks to
me is that we're paying more money than
we're supposed to be paying to you and
you're not paying the amount of money
you're supposed to be paying and then
you're giving all that money to the
people we're supposed to be protecting
you from tell me how that makes sense
and all of the smart people although the
educated people all of the expert people
they say oh well I can't what what a
stupid question why would he ask that
question all pop up and then he said
well what's the answer
said well because that's the way it is
well the way it is isn't gonna work is
it President Trump is so it's so lovely
it's so refreshing to have somebody
who's from outside the political process
who's from outside Washington was from
outside the decades and decades and
decades of minor little changes small
little things adding up to this big
nonsensical situation he comes in and he
says doesn't make any sense I got some
fresh set of eyes it doesn't make any
sense a beautiful thing the left says
Donald Trump is treating our allies like
our our enemies and our enemies like our
allies that's not true at all President
Trump is just looking and he's saying
you know it's not a friendship if you're
being taken advantage of if one friend
is taking advantage of another so-called
friend that isn't a friendship right you
got a you got to be on even footing and
you can't play you know play soft with
these people forever World War two ended
70 years ago there you know that this we
don't need to keep walking around the
situation so President Trump comes in I
think it's a beautiful thing it's not
like by the way they're trying to
pretend that President Trump is being
really nice to Russia the the example
he's using here is that Europe should
stop buying oil from Russia that's
actually what what the ask is isn't it
saying stop buying oil from Russia start
buying oil from not start spending money
on NATO's
spending money in your own defense and
this is possible by the way Poland
doesn't buy oil from Russia
do they there are plenty of places you
know it's certainly possible not to buy
it well from Russia she's saying this
situation doesn't make sense that's a
beautiful thing and the arguments
against it don't make a whole lot of
sense either so on foreign affairs we
really are winning just look around the
world Isis is defeated militarily North
Korea has come to the table now who
knows it looks like they're backing out
of that pretend deal okay nothing
nothing really ventured nothing really
gained but that's fine we still have the
bigger button that actually works and
and is offers a credible threat of
violence in North Korea
the Middle East is doing far better we
finally come back to our ally Israel
whom Barack Obama gave the one-finger
salute to for eight years and we've
we've fulfilled an American promise
that's going on for decades to move the
embassy to Jerusalem that's pretty good
we're allowing Russia to help us in the
Middle East in so much as they can help
us but without any illusions that were
somehow allies now and we have the
identical strategic interests we don't
were finally confronting China China's
been stealing our IP for years making
aggressive military action in the South
China Sea presidents have been whining
about it but they haven't done anything
president Trump is finally forcing them
to the table to negotiate on trade these
are huge wins on foreign policy foreign
policy I don't know could be going
really any better than it is right now
how about on domestic policy the the
federal bureaucracy has been growing and
sprawling and undercutting the the
democratic process for years and years
and years and this is not some new Trump
talking point conservatives have been
talking about this for years Antonin
Scalia said before he died that the
administrative state is the greatest
threat to Liberty in the United States
so are we taking them on here we go
we've got a Republican trey Gowdy taking
on a bureaucrat extraordinaire trying to
undercut a democratic election in 2016
Peter struck here is the committee
hearing you got another text from your
colleague Lisa Paige Trump's not ever
going to become president right right
and you replied no no he's not we'll
stop it by the time you promise to stop
him from becoming president on August
the 8th how many interviews had you
conducted mr. gowdey so two answers that
with regard to how many interviews had
or had not been conducted I've been
directed by counsel for the FBI not to
answer that question second sir I think
it's important to take those texts in
the context of how they were written and
what they meant and there and someone
may ask you that question
agent strong but I didn't I asked you
how many people you interviewed before
you wrote it if you want to get into
context let one of my other colleagues
do that with you here's what I want to
know who's the he and he's not he is
then candidate Trump so when you said no
Donald Trump's not in connection with a
question going to become president
what's the it chairman
stop it chairman Gowdy that text needs
to be taken in the cut I'm asking look
if you want to have a debate over a two
letter word we're gonna have to do that
some all the time what and who did you
mean by it mr. Gowdy as I've stated that
text was written late at night in
shorthand I don't care when it was read
I don't care whether it was longhand
cursive I don't care about any of that I
want to know what it meant
agent struck it would be his candidacy
for the presence that the omit the
important thing here is not that we get
answers from struck we're not going to
get answers from struck he's gonna say I
need to talk to counsel I need to talk
to that I don't know I'm not you know
but at least we're exposing them this is
a this is something that we're finally
able to do because of Technology and
because of the new political climate you
know the left was trying to use the
mainstream media of the federal
bureaucracy whatever any tool at their
disposal to overturn a presidential
election will explain how in just one
second I got to talk about movement you
know how I know that we have to do that
because I'm wearing my movement watch
I love movement I wear this watch every
day you've heard me talk about movement
many times those two college dropouts
that started their own watch company
this company has grown like crazy even
just in the time that we've been talking
about them on the show they now have
sold almost two million watches in 160
plus countries they
continue to revel I revolutionize
fashion on the belief that style
shouldn't break the bank occasionally
they'll send me a freebie and I'm really
hoping they send me more freebies
because they have even cooler watches
out now they're unrolling a few new
collections this one came out a little
while ago the revolver collection I
can't tell you how many compliments I
get on this watch it's really cool
because it's both sleek and modern but
it's got this real retro look it's not
you know it's not too busy it's not got
a million things going on it's just a
really slick looking watch it's it's
come a long way from being crowdfunded
out of a living room they also now have
expanded the sunglasses fashion-forward
bracelets for her or him you know it's
2018 man that's cool get with the
program get with your preferred pronoun
movement watches are all about looking
good and keeping it simple
I really everywhere I go is up and say
in a barber over the weekend people were
complimenting me on this watch and it's
across the spectrum of people so like
sort of traditional you know tie blazers
are wearing conservatives complement it
and also on rare occasion when I'm
hanging out with like cool guys in LA
who have like spiky hair and man buns
and whatever they have a complement it
to it just is really broadly appreciated
movement watches by the way start at
just 95 bucks at a department store you
would pay three four hundred maybe five
hundred bucks for a watch of this
quality but movement cuts out the
middleman they sell direct online so you
don't have that retail markup and that
retail market by the way can be 5 X 4 X
I mean really high classic design
quality construction and style to
minimalism get 15% off today with free
shipping and free returns don't say I
never did nothing for you celebrate this
banner week for American liberty go to
movement calm slash cough f8m VMT
dot-com slash cough FAC o VF e fe you
only put the vowels in this after the
slash before that it's only consonants
then you get vowels after the /cy
movement keeps growing check out their
expanding collection MV m t.com slash co
f fa co v fe fe and join the movement
seriously it's so so nice back to how
the left is subverting a presidential
election they did this to Richard Nixon
the impeachment of Richard Nixon Nixon
won in a landslide they used every tool
at their disposal the press and the
bureaucracy the deep state to overturn
that election they've been trying to do
it again so what they do is they have
this
of a scandal this is the Russia
collusion it's just a facade of a
scandal explain to me how Trump colluded
with Russia just go I'll give you just
have a minute just explain to yourself
think for a second how did Trump collude
with Russia we've been talking about
this for two years now what do I know
how did Trump collude with Russia you
probably can't explain how right because
there's no evidence it's just the facade
of a scandal and what this does what
these hearings do when you get Peter
struck one of the FBI agents
investigating this who clearly had an
anti-trump bias who was saying I'm gonna
use the power of the state to stop Trump
from becoming president when you bring
them up there you cut through that
facade and you expose the American
people to directly what what the
so-called scandal is they see it clearly
this is the great change in 2016 2017
you've got a president who is skipping
the mainstream media talking directly to
the American people largely via Twitter
you've got it you can cut through that
with congressional testimony you can cut
through that with live-streaming you can
get through that with tweeting and cut
that you can just cut through the facade
and see see it for what it really is
this is all about optics and the optics
look really bad for Peter struck here
because he goes on and you can watch the
testimony I wish we had the clip of him
stammering like an idiot but he looks
arrogant he looks guilty he looks like
he's hiding something he obviously is
hiding things because he won't answer
very direct questions that are not that
there is no reason that he shouldn't
answer them other than he's gonna make
himself look like more of a dirtbag than
he already does so you get to see that
directly this is a beautiful thing it's
the same thing by the way with the
stormy Daniels arrest you might have
seen that stormy Daniels was arrested in
a strip club in Ohio for violating state
law that's fine she's you know she's a
stripper it wouldn't be the first time
you know somebody who works primarily in
Vice gets arrested or something like
that but what is it about it's all about
the optics do I really blame stormy
Daniels for the crime of rubbing up on
gentlemen at a strip club no that's sort
of that's what she does right that's her
job
but we get to see it now we actually see
what's happening you know what the left
ones to paint is that stormy Daniels is
this heroic feminist victim of Donald
Trump's a
recive 'no snow she's a she's a
professional stripper who gets paid to
have sex on camera that's what she is
now that doesn't mean you know that she
can't be victimized but she isn't
victimized here that's for sure and
you're just seeing if you were just to
watch the mainstream media sail stormy
Daniels this heroine Joan of Arc you
know but then you say no she gets
arrested for rubbing her her her body
all over men in a strip club that's her
real that's the reality of her life
she's still working to get paid EV sex
on camera she's still working as a
stripper off-camera perhaps she's still
she's still doing that that's the
reality of it she's being she's being
paid to degrade herself and when you
look at what this all of these scandals
are it does seem like they're people who
are getting paid to degrade themselves
you know Michael avenatti is the real
prostitute in the situation because he's
glommed on to these fake scandals and
these facades of scandals to get himself
on CNN 27 hours a day I mean they're
even even the left is finally knocking
him for it they're saying Michael
avenatti is taking down Trump one CNN
hit at a time okay you know this guy
really seems to like the camera it was
dangerous place in the countries between
Michael avenatti and a TV camera but
you're finally seeing that's that's a
very important thing because the the
more that we can show the American
people the reality of this the less
likely they are to buy the left's
ridiculous narrative if they if all the
American people are exposed to is the
narrative they might be duped by it but
luckily the reality is on our side so
all we have to do is just shine a light
and expose it you saw yesterday I played
that clip of CNN CNN was talking to an
illegal alien woman you know said her
child was gone who separated from her
and they asked her how the kids doing
and the woman said D said que esta muy
bien he says he's doing very well
and CNN translated it and said oh it's
everything's terrible and Trump's a
monster and they're crying and it's
awful and but when you've seen the
reality the realities on our side when
you see the fake narrative then people
get confused how bet on the economy so
that's just on the on the bureaucracy
part of it on the economy the economy is
doing so so well people ask me they say
you know the the lefties will try to say
well it's really secretly the economy's
doing very poorly but even though it
seems like it's doing great
the economy has base
I've never been better unemployment is
at an 18-year low there is a labor
shortage right now that's good for two
reasons one there are more jobs to fill
than people to fill them and - it means
wages are going to go up wages have
stagnated for a long time at this point
over over a decade largely they've
stagnated in the middle class and now
wages are going up because there's a
labor shortage that's wonderful a
jobless claims were at a forty four year
low just about all excellent news on the
economy this also ties into the
immigration issue because when you flood
the country with immigrants and illegal
aliens we just tend to go down
especially in certain sectors they can
they can really destroy the labor market
so in that respect Donald Trump is
winning both on the main issue of his
presidency and on the economy which is
what people care about cuz they see it
so viscerally it affects their
pocketbooks on civil rights even this is
one that nobody on the Left is reporting
on but even this week we are winning
tremendously the DOJ under President
Trump is reopening the case of the
murder of Emmett Till of
Emmett Till this murder happened in 1955
it's when a bunch of murderers
killed 14 year old Emmett Till JW Milam
and his half-brother Robert Bryant they
killed him for allegedly flirting with a
white woman there's no evidence really
that he flirted with a white woman but
they killed him for that he came in
Emmett Till came in to town from Chicago
and he was killed brutally murdered and
and you know ripped apart and his mother
actually demanded an open casket funeral
to show the world how gory and awful
this was and and by the way after they
were acquitted a Milam was acquitted
within an hour I think they said the
all-white jury would have acquitted him
sooner except they took a break to have
a soda I mean this was no trial at all a
total total show and Milam confessed
this is what he said the murder of
Emmett Till in 1956 a year later he said
what else could we do he was hopeless
I'm no bully I never hurt he was the
word ninja let's just sing ninja I never
heard a ninja in my life I like and
words in their place I know how to work
them but I just decided it was time a
few people got put on notice as long as
I can live and do anything about it and
n words are gonna stay in their place
and words ain't gonna vote where I live
if they did they'd control the
government
I ain't gonna go to school with my kids
and when an n-word gets close to
mentioning sex with a white woman he's
tired of living I'm likely to kill him
me and my folks fought for this country
we got some rights I stood there in that
shed and listen to that n-word throw
that poison at me and I just made up my
mind Chicago boy I said I'm tired of him
sending your kind down here to stir up
trouble
damn you I'm gonna make an example of
you just so everybody can know how me
and my folks stand and then he viciously
killed him and tied his body to a weight
and drowned him killed him in a river
that was there was the admission now the
the DOJ has new information they've said
they haven't released any information on
what that information is but they have
reopened the case under President Trump
and that is a very good thing so it's
it's ironic that the the President Trump
is being called a racist based on
nothing by the way nobody called him a
racist before he he ran for office as a
Republican now all of a sudden he's a
big racist they're calling him a racist
this guy is focused pretty clearly on
civil rights the example of this is not
too long ago a president Trump issued a
pardon for Jack Johnson Jack Johnson
probably what is it now almost a hundred
years later almost a century later Jack
Johnson was the first black heavyweight
champion boxer I'm not talking about the
pop guitarist that only suburban white
girls like Jack Johnson I'm talking
about the heavyweight boxer black the
first black heavyweight champ boxer so
he Jack Johnson was serving a ten month
stint at Leavenworth in 1921 and his
crime basically was traveling with a
white woman what he was convicted on was
the Mann Act for bringing a prostitute
across state lines the Mann Act was to
stop human trafficking but Jack Johnson
and Jack Johnson had a checkered past
with women I'm not saying this guy was
the same do you know but it was a
consensual relationship he was in with
this woman and he was basically arrested
for for the racial crime of traveling
with a white woman and Woodrow Wilson of
course wouldn't grant him the pardon and
both President Bush and President Obama
were asked to pardon Jack Johnson
posthumously and they said no it's not
no we're not gonna do it
I don't what's the point it's a it's a
little dicey because he had a checkered
past himself and
don't want to do it president Trump
heard about this and he said yeah let's
do it of course that's justice
it was injustice that he got arrested it
was obviously a racial thing and we're
gonna have pardoned him this is only the
third posthumous pardon by any US
president and president Trump did it why
is this apparently strong focus on civil
rights that's that's a pretty good thing
I've got a second bite of Facebook in a
second but I do want to clear up some
questions on the court because this is
the real area that we're winning and I
think there's a little misinformation
out there people a lot of conservatives
were very excited about justice or judge
Amy Kony Barrett because she seemed so
rock-ribbed worked for Scalia very
pro-life but more importantly would be a
textualist and therefore the pro-life
cause probably would win and this guy
you know he doesn't cease doesn't seem
quite as rock-ribbed to some people that
said he's pretty good first of all they
can't they have nothing on this guy The
Washington Post found the big scandal on
him the scandal is Supreme Court nominee
piled up credit card debt by purchasing
Nationals tickets so and by the way he
paid off the credit card debt so that so
basically the headline is Brett
Kavanaugh used credit cards ever and
went to America's favorite pastime he
also likes Brett Kavanaugh piled up
credit card debt eating apple pie okay
sure
you know and they and they said he
doesn't have a lot he's not rich he only
has assets between 15 and $60,000 that
is a Brett Kavanaugh has spent his
career in the public sector as a judge
if he were rich that would throw up red
flags wouldn't it but he's there what
they're saying is breaking Brett
Kavanaugh apparently too upright a
citizen to dignified a judge to soon
make a lot of money on the side this is
a very good thing so everything they try
to throw at him it just doesn't work at
all and he's got a ton of the pro-life
credibility that's the other thing
people are trying to say he won't
overturn roe v-- wade who knows how
he'll rule who knows if a court with
cabin on it will overturn roe v wade it
certainly seems it will whittle away at
it but he's got a lot of pro-life cred
he did say he did ruling Garza V Oregon
that the as the ACLU tried to argue
that's an illegal alien has some right
to an abortion on demand he said that
was ridiculous and that was right he
ruled for the pre
for life in priests for life roaches 8
vs HHS on the question of religious
liberty and whether they have to provide
a board of fashion drugs abortion drugs
- - Chuck Schumer in 2006 he he did say
that roe v wade is binding precedent but
a lot of pro lifers are saying this is
the scary this is the big red flag they
said it's a binding precedent that's not
a big deal only because he prefaced it
he said if confirmed to the DC Circuit
if confirmed sure as a lower court judge
he can't overturn roe v wade of course
not but the language but you have to
watch the precise language earth judges
used very precise language that's like
their job you know he also they said the
same thing about Gorsuch coursethe said
similar things and nobody is saying that
he's he's a weakling on abortion or on
roe v-- wade and then during AEI speech
American Enterprise Institute judge
Cavanaugh said he alluded to the general
tide of freewheeling judicial creation
of unenumerated rights that were not
rooted in the nation's history and
tradition he's talking about roe v wade
and that's pretty strong language the
judicial creation of rights that were
not rooted in the nation's history and
tradition taking a pretty hard swing and
he's talking about it in that if you
read the speech carefully he starts
talking about it right after he talks
about slavery as this great flaw this
great oversight this great American
crime and I think that juxtaposition is
important because the argument against
abortion is is the argument against
slavery you don't have a right to do
something to another person to kill
another person to steal their Liberty
just to take their life you know the the
argument for overturning roe v wade is a
constitutional one the argument for
pro-life is the same argument for
abolition it's the same one you don't
have a right to oppress people tyrannize
people kill them take their labor and
the fact that he's just opposing those
two things that's a very good sign and
then finally all right I've got to say
goodbye to Facebook and YouTube I'll
talk about how we're winning the
religious war then we'll have to get to
the mailbag but before that before that
if you're on facebook and youtube go to
daily wire.com you're probably not on
YouTube because YouTube's clamping down
on us now YouTube actually is
manipulating the subscription feed to
curate your choices you might have seen
this news article to curate your choices
to put all the lefties up at the top and
bury conservatives that means that users
might not get notified if a channel goes
live
even if you subscribe to our channel so
in order to make sure you still get
notifications go to not only subscribe
to daily wire on YouTube but also ring
the little bell so that you will get
subscriptions when we post content what
do you get ten bucks a month hundred
dollars for an annual membership you get
me the Andrew Clavin show that Ben
Shapiro show you get to ask questions in
the mailbag you get to ask questions in
the conversation none of that matters a
banner week everything going well and
drink the you're gonna need this to
drink the Peter struck vintage right now
I know he's not talking a lot on camera
in this testimony but he or those tears
flowing behind the camera offstage make
sure you have this or you might drown
when a daily wire calm
we'll be right back a lot more of the
show to go
we're winning the religious war too this
is the final this is kind of the
foundational part of how we're winning
so hard this week you've seen a lot of
religious conversations come up it was
spurred by this Supreme Court nomination
fight because you had the fight over roe
v wade you had the fight over people who
are Catholic who are being nominated for
this court you know they're members of
cults according to the left so the New
York Times ran this piece today called
when politicians determine your
religious beliefs and there's this
religious divide in America and what
they're trying to say well here's what
it here's what they right quote at first
glance president Trump's nomination of
Judge Cavanaugh where the Supreme Court
would seem a perfect reminder of why so
many religious white Americans of vote
Republican to promote conservative moral
values religious values their values the
values that the story goes devout white
Protestants and Catholics want to see in
Washington before we go on or what what
does white have anything to do with it
and really what does religion have
anything to do with it I don't know if
the New York Times is being obtuse here
if or if they're just that stupid it's
one of the two they're either being
really obtuse or they're just being
stupid that the fight is over
constitutionality the fight is over
whether there's a fake right to abortion
in the Constitution there's obviously no
right to abortion in the Constitution
that's what the fight is about or we're
going to interpret the Constitution by
what it says or are we going to
interpret it by what lefties fantasize
it could say are we gonna have a rule of
law we're gonna have a rule of nine
robed dictators in the country leftist
dictators that's what it's about
it's nothing about religion really and
it's certainly nothing about being white
but the New York Times has to throw that
in there because they either they don't
have any idea what they're talking about
or they're being really cynically obtuse
the piece goes on there because there
were some interesting parts in it quote
it's not just that our religious beliefs
affect our politics it's that our
politics affect our religious choices we
don't just take cues about politics from
our pastors and priests we take cues
about religion from our politicians
analyzing these data
I find that twenty-something Democrats
and Republicans were equally secular you
know when they're young teenagers
20-somethings they're equally secular
most had pulled away from religion after
high school and Democrats and
Republicans did so it's similar rate
but nine years later Republicans had
become much more likely to attend church
than their Democrat counterparts in
contrast even those who bucked the
secular trend and remained religious in
their 20s were no more likely than less
religious members of their cohort to
join the Republican ranks in their 30s
okay
what why is that because I actually
would do sort of grant them that premise
that people but Republicans and
Democrats fall away from religion
largely in their teens and early 20s
they come back to it and Republicans
come back to it more more easily and
more quickly why well for one New York
Times perhaps this hasn't occurred to
you that in your teens and 20s what are
you doing you're exploring questions
you're finally fully rational or
approaching full rationality or finally
a little bit educated at least and you
start questioning the world around you
you're no longer a little child you're
becoming an adult you're figuring out
what you think is it possible that
people are analyzing religious questions
and political questions at the same time
when you were a young person did you
analyze religious and political
questions at the same time duh
of course you did that's what people do
they question everything around them
they didn't say okay I'm gonna solve
this question the political question
then I'll have religious views not at
all they both want to deny free will and
rational choice and then say that one
leads to the other necessarily it
doesn't quite work and why else might
this be the case well there is some
social proof you know when you win if
you're a lefty and you see all these
other you think oh yeah I really like
Obama you see all these other lefties
mocking religion and people that you
might respect mocking religion you say
okay well I guess that's true I'll take
a shortcut I won't think about the
question too hard I'll just take this
shortcut there's certainly that maybe
you're compelled by the arguments of
those who associate with I was agnostic
bordering on atheism in my teens and
early 20s and I would talk to people
whose views I respected on politics and
they might explain to me why I was wrong
about religion and I might say oh well
if you're right about all these other
things maybe you're right about this too
maybe I'm wrong it's called humility New
York Times I know you know nothing about
this but it's called intellectual
humility and it's called intellectual
curiosity nothing of which interests the
New York Times and and of course the
final reason is that we're leftist
Democrats politics supplants religion
when Diane Feinstein is worried that the
dogma lives loudly within Catholics
because the dog
supplants the leftist dogma it means
that there's no room for the leftist
modern dogma to be there and that and
Democrats who have everybody's got to
serve somebody so if you don't serve God
you're going to serve something else and
you're gonna serve idols of politics be
it environmentalism be its social
justice redistribution Marxist ideology
whatever you're going to serve something
and unfortunately for for people on the
left broadly and in the Democratic Party
now broadly that is that's a question
that is that's a void that's filled by
shallow politics although the way we're
winning on this too is that among the
coalition of the ascendant to use the
Democrats phrase blacks and Hispanic
voters are more likely to agree with
Republicans on questions of religion so
it's splitting their own base it's
splitting their own party very good news
and maybe it'll bring them to the good
Lord alright we've got a little bit of
time left for mailbag I was running late
today so let's jump right into it from
Anthony hey Michael I'm a big fan while
doing research into the case of roe v--
wade I was reading up on the Fourteenth
Amendment which states all persons born
or naturalized in the u.s. cannot be
deprived of life liberty or property
without due process my question is if
the text specifically says born are
naturalized
would a child in the womb meet this
standard as it's not yet born no I don't
think it does I don't think the child in
the womb
I don't think abortion is
unconstitutional because of the 14th
amendment the language is clear born or
naturalized in a child in the womb I
don't think yet certainly hasn't been
born I don't think it's been naturalized
I don't think the way that we should
stop abortion is by pretending that
there's a constitutional prohibition
against abortion there's certainly no
constitutional right to abortion and
there's no constitutional prohibition of
it
so roe v wade should be overturned
because it's blatantly unconstitutional
and then the question should be decided
by the people and you know freedom is
scary because people might decide to
legalize murder and something morally
similar to murder in certain states in
New York California wherever but you'll
I think you'll get much more of an ethic
of life and if by the way if this is
debated freely and we don't just pretend
that there's either of right to an
abortion or prohibition of abortion in
the Constitution our side is gonna win I
said this earlier in the show when you
show reality
we win because unlike leftist ideologue
who say who cares if a work in practice
doesn't work in theory I think the
reality is on our side there's something
about the conservative disposition that
really favours the real the tangible the
what we see before us and we don't
really doubt our lyin eyes so much like
the left does I think we shouldn't be
afraid of freedom and we shouldn't play
the game of the left of perverting the
Constitution I think that's we're gonna
lose that one in the long run
next question from Garrett Lorde and
Noel's I've heard an argument that we
have no free will because we can't
control our desires and all of our
actions are based on what we want to do
if you reply with examples of you acting
against your desires a defender of this
argument would reply that you only did
that because you wanted to go against it
and therefore we are back to square one
what are your thoughts on this to me it
seems like all it did was prove that we
can create an ad hoc justification for
any of our actions that means it's
related to desires I'm unsure if this is
a logical fallacy thanks and love the
show yeah it's ridiculous it's what
they're saying is unfalsifiable
sentiment and nonsense obviously you can
think of times that you act against your
desires namely all of the time because
there's a moral order you know if I'm
walking down the street and I see a cute
little lass you know well I would never
feel any desire at all because I'm
because sweet little ELISA listens to
this show so I've got to make clear I
don't even see other women it's like
people who say they don't see color I
don't even see them I just want said
what are you hello sir nice to meet you
I'm a lady
yeah well sir I'm sorry I don't see
gender but obviously people stop they're
sort of basis too animalistic desires
because we have higher desires we have
love for our wives why don't we why
don't we just go cheap with every single
woman we see because there's this base
animalistic sexual attraction but then
we have this higher love for our wives
we have a moral order that we have to
follow
why don't we murder people that we don't
like because there's a moral order that
we follow obviously we but against that
now they say well really your desire is
to follow the moral order sure but if
what you're saying by the way is that we
can't we cannot can ultimately
everything is just determined by this
animalistic thing then you have no
rational faculties
you have no faculties of reason to
discern between two
judgment to discern between a base
desire and sort of higher calling or the
right thing to do and if you have no
faculties of reason then what you were
saying is not reliable because you're
not accessing truth you're just
motivated by your natural desires if
that's true you're an animal and you
might be an animal you're a lefty friend
might be an animal but you're not an
animal and and if they say yes we have
no rational faculties than what they're
saying has no meaning they're there
they're not actually making a rational
statement they're just saying bah bah
bah bah right it's like when people say
there's no free will and I'd start
punching them in the face
and they'd say stop doing that I say I'm
not doing it I have no free will it's
just this was just preordained to happen
I'm sorry I'm not even sorry because
it's not my fault cuz I have no moral
culpability
it's a ridiculous argument and they're
just making unfalsifiable sentimental
claims from Alicia do we have time we
have time for like a few more from
Alicia Michael oh I don't know what
language that's in what are the chances
that the Dems would come up with a new
candidate who would you pick for a
Democrat nominee in 2020 that's easy Jim
Acosta no question Jim Acosta won
because he looks like a generic
president you know he's just like a sort
of glib guy with silly hair you know
perfectly quaffed hair and everything
which looks good on some people but Jim
Acosta would also be a great choice
because first of all he's the mouthpiece
of Democrats he's he oh he only does is
repeat Democrat talking points on on
like automatic he's just on this
automatic function and he's already on
the CNN mouthpiece of Iran the Democrat
mouthpiece of CNN he's already on their
main communications platform so that
would be pretty helpful and also it
would really rile up the Democrats
because he's a straight white man as far
as I know so they're gonna say oh gosh
he is he is the avatar of Democrats but
we have to hate straight white guys now
so what are what do we do about it
Rarawa and they rip them apart and be
really good and the the simpler answer
is Hillary Clinton it looks like she may
run might be more likely that she runs
again but who knows if the Democrats
will successfully reanimate that corpse
in time for 2020 otherwise my money's on
Jim Acosta from misty hi Michael one
quick question good I'm glad I'm glad
this is a quick question what is the
quick question what does the Bible
actually have to say about purgatory and
whether or not it does exist spoiler
alert this is not a quick question this
will be a long question
as myself I'm a Protestant and don't
believe in purgatory and wanted to know
a Catholics view on it because it
doesn't give me a direct answer I don't
have a direct answer okay thanks James
sure happy to do that this is going to
be a longer one it long story short
purgatory is rooted in Scripture and in
sacred tradition and it exists we see
this where are some places in Scripture
in Maccabees you see quote he turned to
prayer beseeching that the sin which had
been committed it might be wholly
blotted out
he also took up a collection and sent it
to Jerusalem to provide for a sin
offering in doing this he acted very
well and honorably therefore he made
atonement for the dead
that they might be delivered from their
sin so this is a clear example in
Scripture of of people praying for the
dead that the dead after they are dead
might be delivered from sins that they
had committed while they were alive so
that I think that's a clear allusion to
to purgatory
now one trouble with the Protestant
revolution is after the Protestant
revolution various denominations just
started taking out books of the Bible
Martin Luther did this he said we're
only gonna rely on Scripture but only
the scripture that I like and all the
one that I don't like I'm gonna pull out
of the Bible I don't know if that's Sola
scriptura buddy we also see this in the
New Testament if you're not compelled by
Maccabees in Matthew 12 whoever says a
word against the Son of Man will be
forgiven but whoever speaks against the
Holy Spirit will not be forgiven either
in this age or in the age to come this
is an enigmatic scripture I'm not going
to explain or try to explain why
speaking against the Holy Spirit will
not be forgiven but I will point out it
says either in this age or in the age to
come so our Lord is presenting a clear
case that sins can be forgiven in this
age or in the age to come so I that
seems to validate what we saw in in
Maccabees I don't think our Jesus
misspeaks he doesn't really miss speak
he speaks perfectly and there is a
premise here that you can be forgiven
for your sins in this age or in the age
to come some sins then in Matthew 5 it's
a little clearer make friends quickly
with your accuser while you're going
with him to court lest your accuser hand
you over to the judge and the judge to
the guard and you
put in prison truly I say to you you
will never get out till you have paid
the last penny now I don't I don't think
our Lord is being clever by half here I
don't think he's saying and you'll never
pay the last penny ha ha ha but he is
saying you will pay for this you will
have to there will be some consequence
for your sins and but you can get out I
don't think you say you can you can
never get out you can get out in from
certain sins in certain cases
Tertullian in writing not long after the
death of Christ and 208 ad describes
that exactly as such and is parabolic
but the clearest example if I haven't
convinced you so far I hope I have is in
first Corinthians which reads quote for
no other foundation can anyone lay than
that which is laid which is Jesus Christ
now if anyone builds on the foundation
with gold silver precious stones wood
hay stubble each man's work will become
manifest for the day will disclose it
because it will be revealed with fire
and the fire will test what sort of work
each one has done if the work which any
man has built on the foundation survives
he will receive a reward if any man's
work is burned up he will suffer loss
though he himself will be saved but only
as through fire only as through fire and
the image of purgatory is as a cleansing
and self saving fire that purifies your
refining fire that purifies you for
heaven I know that certain denominations
took out books of the Bible but I don't
think they took out Corinthians so
there's the scriptural evidence for that
is there I'll take this one last quick
one then we got a sign-off from Noah had
an argument with two of my co-workers
and they said Obama's economy was better
than Trump's six the tax cuts my
coworker has said thousands of people
lost their jobs
he showed me a Vox article or it stop
right there he's going to show you like
occupy Democrats Hey he showed me this
meme on the internet okay
he showed me a Vox article it was a list
of 12 companies that were laying off
employees because of because of the tax
cuts okay
overall or the tax cuts good why did
these companies layoff so many people
okay here's what you need to know we
have a massive labor shortage in the
country there are more jobs than people
to fill them right now I do
do companies sometimes fire people yeah
do they fire people because they've just
gotten more money to spend
no that doesn't make any sense no
company fires people because they now
have more money through tax cuts
no just look at the numbers we have a
massive labor shortage I think I
mentioned this earlier in the show
jobless claims are at an almost forty
four year low and we have the lowest
unemployment in 18 years
no it helped end the IMF admits by the
way that the global economic boom is in
part caused by President Trump and it's
directly attributable to him so I think
the main mistake your friend made was
reading voxcom and and not retreating it
like everyday feminism or whatever other
ridiculous lefty dishonest sites there
are okay that's all the time we have we
have other great questions to get to but
not enough time have a good weekend
everybody I hope you can make it through
and you know swim some laps and all
those leftist tears and then I'll see
you on Monday in the meantime I'm
Michael Knowles and this is the Michael
Knowles show
the Michael Nolt show is produced by
semia Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stevens edited by Jim nickel
audio is mixed by mic core Amina hair
and makeup is by Jeshua alvera the
Michael Knowles show is a daily wire for
word publishing production copyright for
word publishing 2018